well we expected Chris Rock to go all in
on Will Smith but what we didn't expect
rocking the boat with Meghan Markle and
the royal family welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight Chris Wade of
nearly a year to say his piece about the
Oscar slap but the big question now
what's next as Chris said his selective
outrage straight to the Smiths
heavyweight fight I got summertime
ringing in my ear
s
everybody that really knows knows I had
nothing to do with that I didn't have
any entanglements an entanglement yes
his wife was her son's friend everybody
in him been cheated on none of us have
ever been interviewed by the person that
cheated on us on television because I
wasn't sure I was ever going to speak to
you again she heard him way
okay
for seven minutes on his live stream
special you could say Chris slap back at
will everybody call them
and who's he hit me
I think Chris got through it and of
course came out on top I've never had
Revenge live on Netflix before so I'm
pretty sure that critical feels amazing
are they shooting is that Willow
but one joke about Will's role as a
slave stirred in online backlash and now
now just to see him get whooped
critics Called It Sick tasteless and not
funny Chris however was pretty pleased
with the show we're told he's in a great
place and felt like the performance was
a chance to Exhale as for what's next
our source says the comedian left
Baltimore yesterday morning and plans to
now take at least a month off of course
will wasn't Chris's only celebrity
Target he also slammed Meghan Markle
acting all dumb like she don't know
nothing going on Oprah I didn't know I
had no idea how racist they were after
Ryan
hey
you didn't do this
it's the royal family then the original
racist
they invented colonialism that's right
marrying into the Budweiser family and
going they drink a lot
[Music]